are you ready for this Evan always
always ready you did Camelback Mountain
on your first try minimal stops you guys
question congratulations I have a Days
full of highlights
[Music]
good morning Evan Carmichael good
morning Nina Carmichael
today is Friday today's Friday what are
we doing today today is Friday is
normally my CEO day so one day per week
to work on big things to grow my
business work on the business not in the
business today is a little bit of an
exception we've got um
Eddie Panero a friend of the channels
got his own YouTube channel about half a
million Subs your world within is in
town for two days and we're gonna go do
some interviews with him for his channel
we're going to then go hiking up
Camelback Mountain which apparently is a
a must do here we're going up the hard
way uh where we're like climbing ropes
and stuff apparently so that'll be
interesting then we're gonna go to
optimize and do Asana and cold plunge
and then go for dinner and who knows
what other amazing things will happen
because life with Nina is always
unexpected and
let's go
[Music]
all right we got to genius Network I
have to film Maya yeah yeah I have to
film Evan I forgot get it right Nina's
reminded me about uh what I need to do
Evan and Eddie will be filming in here
what's E Square
well e squared is
oh okay
they're gonna do some interview here but
check out this Library here that's a lot
of books
I wonder how much Joe has read all these
books Joe has read a lot of books yeah
[Music]
Joe polish here yes he's doing an
interview with Eddie yeah
you're gonna express some wisdom today
probably not I was thinking that we
would really use this as just an r d
session on how to handle people that
don't share any wisdom whatsoever when
you're interviewing them because then
when you are around smart people which
is certainly not going to happen today
you can you know you'll be better
prepared for it by dealing with the
difficult ones it's going to be wisdom
box he's a very nice person behind the
scenes and uh and this is behind the
scenes like a curmudgeon sometimes uh
first off there's nothing as a
curmudgeon about it's just humor because
humor what comedy is is pain plus time
equals comedy and so if you have pain in
your life give it a little bit of time
you can come up with some funniness so
try to be funny that's all I'm saying
just try to be funny it's too many not
funny people
thank you
they had a great interview
and then
Eddie's eating oh you're filming me yeah
Eddie Eddie uh I guess that was Eddie's
first interview that was great Eddie
asked some great questions then we
talked about
running podcasts and then he did Joe
afterwards and and asked even better
questions
and uh they went overtime on what they
were supposed to talk so then now
Eddie's got to eat in the car it's like
all right Nina's like should we go
interrupt him we gotta go I was like no
Eddie we'll just sit in the car it's not
a problem yeah turn around yeah
so Eddie's hitting his pokeball in the
car and we're on our way to Camelback
Mountain we are confirmed taking the
harder way let's go people were like no
he's not going to take you the heart
away he's going to take you the easy way
and uh it's like what entrance are you
going to and Echo something which is the
harder way so we have to climb ropes to
get up and all this stuff so whatever
let's go Camelback Mountain onwards
are you ready for this Evan always
always ready
if I Collapse Eddie Panera well
fireman's carry me down all the way
instead of just throwing me down
we're ready get our hike on
okay we are here at Echo something Trail
we got our Camelback Mountain our guy
Camelback Mountain we got Michael
I'm already tired just walking up I'm
tired too walking now up the hill
Michael yeah we got Michael we got we
got Nina we got Jake we got Tyler and we
got Eddie this is our crew we're gonna
hike the mountain should take us I don't
know 35 40 minutes up
about 35-40 minutes down it's like
straight up just take some good videos
to see that and it's probably one of the
local sites to see here in Phoenix but
also one of the harder hikes as well so
you need good cardio
and you need a strong mind to keep going
let's go
[Music]
and we climb up from there
that's where we started and now we're
here
so apparently this is the hill that we
have to go up
Tina's vlogging this too yeah I'm tired
of camel guy it's right here
so you can either zigzag or I highly
recommend you clicking the poll and be
safe about it
it's the best we love suffering
[Music]
foreign
control of Arizona
[Music]
hello
um
enough we're going back down yeah ready
to go back it's supposed to be easier
but more dangerous because you're going
down yeah so we're ready we made it up
now we can make it down
why don't you go in front of me no I
guess I should go in front of you so I
could stop you if you fall I'm not gonna
Lean Forward yeah slow steps
[Music]
no we just uh finished hiking the
Camelback the hard way Michael thank you
for taking us is it great yeah
you did Camelback Mountain on your first
try minimal stops you guys crushed it
congratulations
all right now we have to optimize to get
compression sauna cold Plunge hot tub
and then we'll see what happens let's do
it yeah
[Music]
we are going to optimize right now to
release the stress that we just went
through yeah
body hurts yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so I left early because I haven't we
haven't seen the dogs for the whole day
they were just basically at the Airbnb
the whole day themselves I need to go
home feed them and take them out
oh man that was so cold in the cold
plant today although I did like six and
a half minutes but I was so cold and
then when I got out I looked at myself I
was like holy cow my lips are purple
yeah that was happened anyways happy to
go home see the Ducks and feed them
hello Timo
hello
it's just dinner
Tristan that's very blurry for some
reason
are you happy to see me
I just got back to pick up Evan
and they just they're they're done Eddie
is leaving departing
and uh had an amazing time with you guys
met some awesome people learned some
awesome stuff had some great
conversations
excited to keep leveling up so let's go
appreciate it much love
were we heading to heaven
we're heading to dinner
um
initially the plan was say goodbye to
Eddie and uh he's off to go you know
film some videos and we had a great
couple days together
and he leaves tomorrow morning so it's
like hey say goodbye have fun and I was
gonna go
spend some quiet time with Nina you know
we haven't had quiet time for a while uh
but then Joe uh invited us to dinner so
we're going for dinner
we're going for dinner Friday night Nina
already took the dogs out and fed them
so we're gonna go enjoy some pizza I
believe I'm always good I'm always down
for pizza my mouth is water right now I
might Drool on myself as I see the
scores we got some pizza and some good
conversation
and um oh here we go
Evan's favorite food pizza
this is the restaurant that we're going
right now
foreign
[Music]
just finished our amazing meal and Joe
insisted that he get the final message
of the day so we've got to not insist
that but the final message of the day is
today or tonight is the last day of the
way you used to be if you read my book
no in all seriousness have a wonderful
evening call up someone that you love
tell them that you love them or you care
about them if you don't have anyone in
your life that you love or care about
you need to be a more caring person and
that may perhaps manifest itself believe
you had a good time Evan yeah
yeah it was good Chad good chat good
people what's the highlight of the day
spending time with Nina
you spend time every day with me then I
have a Days full of highlights
wait was that good that's good yeah
good okay so we're going home yeah if
you guys want to see what we did on our
last adventure which was what Phoenix
with Joe
Phoenix with Joe gems gem show oh that
was Tucson the Tucson gem show with Joe
was amazing check the video right at the
next verse I think you'll love it
continue to believe see you there